what's up guys so as you guys already
know RAM prices are seriously jacked up
what used to be $150 Ram is now two
hundred and twenty dollars and picking
up the same kit is considered a great
deal and steel if you're able to find it
for $170 so what happened but before we
start if you're a nerd interested in
when I think GPU prices will go down
then make sure to click the link in
description below to check out what I
have to say about that many of you guys
already know what happened but just to
recap high-end smartphones like the
iPhone and a Galaxy series have begun to
employ ddr4 ram and with the release of
Rison many budget gamers saw the valiant
rise in CPUs and quickly jumped on to
building a new PC using ddr4 Ram as well
as many new builders who also purchased
in your program where ever utilizes a
mantra called a NAND flash and this
module is also used in SSDs as a result
the fast trend towards SSDs has also
increased the need for NAND flash
overall in the past year NAND flash has
had a lot more demand but not enough
supply obviously Ram companies have seen
this and they're probably contributing
to a portion of the increase in price
because they know that there is so much
demand that even if they increased their
price up there around we would still buy
it in the end there's a lot of need for
ddr4 Ram so the prices of ddr4 Ram is
currently very high but when will it go
down well a November of last year
Samsung started to increase their DRAM
production for upgrading and expanding
their production facility this were
largely increased availability of ram
components for companies like Coursera
and g.skill but when will these
improvements have an effect on a market
price itself well here is the bad news
most news outlets and Forbes suggest
that the price at the ramp or plateau in
the second quarter of 2018 and then
slowly began their descent
however this is still a couple of months
just for the RAM prices start going down
personally I don't think they will start
to go down until the third quarter of
this year
because a demand would still be so high
that the companies can still pull off
these outrageous prices for a little bit
more but I do believe that the prices
will drop during the third quarter of
this year and by the holiday season of
they should be a MSRP or even beating it
due to the discounts or various sales
for Black Friday Cyber Monday or even
Christmas however if you get to this
point
there is a major hurdle to cross there
are probably thousands of other PC
enthusiasts who refuse to overpay for
their PC parts just like you as a result
they do have probably been keeping a
keen eye out on to when the RAM prices
will hit MSRP therefore stock could run
very quickly and you may not be able to
purchase one due to the sheer quantity
of other buyers with your same
perception unfortunately even if you're
able to get it before others that is
still eight to nine months away from now
so what should you do well if you really
need a computer or you are able to spend
extra cash for the RAM but prefer not to
and I recommend you you might as well
just go ahead and buy it because I
really don't see a ram prices dropping
in the imminent creature however if we
don't really need an upgrade and then
you should just hold off because a few
more gigabytes of RAM or the newer ddr4
Ram with some extra speed it's really
not going to make a difference in dated
performance or even gaming performance
or work performance and you can save
some cash by waiting if you guys are on
a tight budget then I recommend that you
guys just buy a 1 by 8 kit of ddr4 Ram
right now to get you buy until the
holiday season where you can save some
money and hopefully be able to get RAM
for normal prices if you're lucky I
don't think you should go for ddr3 RAM
or anything lower because I don't think
that is a smart decision to be it to buy
an outdated product I recommend to just
get a ddr4 1 by 8 kit and save some more
money until you can afford another one
may take it over all it really depends
on how bad you want the RAM and how much
patience you have if you have the money
I recommend we just get it because it is
going to take at least a couple of
months for prices drop and I don't think
the saving in cash is actually worth it
but for you guys who really need the
prices to go down I'm sorry but I don't
believe the RAM prices will go down till
at least July
well guys that's all I have for you guys
this time make sure to post where you
guys think in the comments down below
I read all my comments and I'm curious
to what you guys are thinking well guys
if you like this video then make sure to
drop a like if you guys love it and
would like to see more videos just like
this then make sure to subscribe but
that's all I have for you guys this time
until next video
bye